Amen.
Donc nous voici devant une grande doctrine,
un Dieu grand,
il a des doctrines grandes, glorieuses.
Et le plus on se plonge dans ces doctrines
qui sont parfois difficiles à comprendre, à saisir,
bien sûr qu'elles ne seront jamais comprises de manière exhaustive,
mais le plus on se plonge
dans la considération de la révélation biblique,
le plus on est reconnaissant vers Dieu,
le plus on est réconforté,
et le plus on a la capacité d'adorer un Dieu grand.
Et donc, un mot par rapport à l'ordre
où cette doctrine est placée,
dans notre système d'études des grandes vérités bibliques,
donc c'est ça, les buts des confessions des fois.
Donc on commence par les Écritures,
car on sait que Dieu a inspiré la parole de Dieu,
et nous n'avons aucune assurance,
nous n'avons aucune autre source des connaissances
à part la Bible,
que nous sommes devant un livre sous la confirmation divine,
dans lequel nous pouvons avoir l'assurance
d'apprendre à propos des dieux et de notre rédemption.
C'est la parole de Dieu.
Donc on doit commencer par là,
car c'est la base d'autorité par rapport à toutes les autres choses
qu'on doit étudier.
La doctrine la plus réconfortante n'est pas si tant celle des Écritures,
mais elle est nécessaire pour qu'on puisse se plonger dans la doctrine la plus réconfortante.
Les festins de l'âme, c'est étudier sur Dieu,
qui Dieu est dans son être absolu, dans ses attributs.
Et donc voilà pourquoi on commence par la Bible,
pour être très sûr que c'est dans la Bible que Dieu lui-même se révèle,
et on essaye, quand on étudie sur Dieu et sur la Sainte Trinité,
on essaye d'étudier directement ce que la Bible révèle à propos des dieux,
de ses attributs de son être.
Donc c'est là les festins de l'âme, c'est les sommets.
Et ensuite, on a considéré, on commence à considérer,
non seulement par ce qui Dieu est,
mais par ce qui Dieu fait,
la gloire de Dieu.
Donc la gloire que Dieu possède dans son être,
se manifeste dans les œuvres de Dieu.
Et voilà pourquoi on part de la doctrine sur Dieu et la Sainte Trinité
envers la doctrine des œuvres de Dieu.
Et on commence par les décrets de Dieu.
On appelle les décrets de Dieu dans les singuliers,
car avant de faire les choses,
Dieu étant intelligent,
un Dieu qui n'a pas de plan B,
un Dieu qui planifie les choses parfaitement,
il a planifié toutes les choses qui viennent à l'existence,
et c'est ces décrets de Dieu
qui vont assembler tous les autres petits plans de Dieu
ou décrets de Dieu qui sont subservients à ces grands décrets de Dieu.
Donc en ayant planifié toutes les choses parfaitement,
avant de créer,
et avant même de développer cette histoire qu'il va soutenir,
dans les cadres des décrets de Dieu se trouve la création,
et toute l'histoire de l'humanité,
tout a été décrété par les conseils sages,
immuables de Dieu.
Et il a commencé à mettre en exécution sa création.
Selon ses plans éternels,
Dieu a créé toutes les choses.
Quand on a étudié la création,
on a commencé par la considération de ce que Dieu a créé
dans les mondes spirituels,
car les mondes spirituels étaient créés avant les mondes naturels,
et donc on a étudié la doctrine sur les anges aussi.
Et ensuite, on a passé à considérer la création de l'univers,
et je vous rappelle,
nous avons étudié,
qui est bibliquement parlant,
et par la confession historique de l'Église,
Dieu a créé toutes les choses,
visibles et invisibles,
pour ce qui concerne l'univers,
dans une période de six jours littéral,
et il a créé fiat ex nihil,
c'est-à-dire par sa parole puissante,
par un décret, par une déclaration,
Dieu a créé toutes les choses,
et il a créé toutes les choses à partir de rien.
Et ensuite, on a considéré la couronne de cette création,
on a donné un peu plus d'importance à la considération
de l'homme et la femme étant créés à l'image des dieux.
Tout cela, on a déjà parcouru,
et maintenant on va considérer la providence.
Et donc, certains, ou certaines systématiques,
certains études systématisées de la parole des dieux,
ils vont faire une légère inversion dans cet ordre,
c'est-à-dire, au lieu de considérer la providence
après la création de l'homme,
ils considèrent la providence avant la création de l'homme.
Pourquoi ?
Car dans la dynamique du récit biblique de Genèse,
on voit clairement que Dieu crée toutes les choses,
mais il crée aussi une espèce de maintenance
et de préparation,
un fonctionnement qui déclenche
la maintenance de l'existence de toutes les choses,
afin que cet univers ait des lois qui régissent cet univers,
afin qu'il puisse se pourvoir à l'homme lui-même
en tant qu'est couronne de la création.
Donc, pour donner encore plus d'importance
à l'homme en tant qu'image des dieux dans cet univers,
on considère avec la création
la manière dont Dieu a établi les lois,
ok, de la providence
pour que cet univers puisse être favorable
aux mentiens envers l'homme
et les mentiens que l'homme porterait aussi
dans son interaction avec la création.
Donc, c'est pour donner un peu plus d'importance
ou pour mettre plus en phase
par rapport à l'homme, ok ?
Mais comme la providence,
elle n'est pas limitée,
donc soyez avec moi,
comme la providence n'est pas limitée
tout simplement au mentiant de l'homme
dans cet acte créateur des dieux,
nous savons que la providence des dieux
est un acte continuel
pendant toute l'histoire de l'humanité.
Et donc, c'est Dieu qui va continuer de soutenir
et même après la chute,
c'est Dieu qui va préserver
et par sa patience,
au lieu de permettre
que cet univers soit complètement détruit
par la rébellion de la chute,
c'est la patience des dieux aussi
qui va maintenir,
qui va permettre que son soleil
continue de s'élever
pour les justes et pour les injustes.
Et donc, pour donner une vision
plus large envers la providence,
la providence des dieux comprend
non seulement les mentiens originales
à l'occasion de la création,
en vue de l'homme,
mais c'est aussi un acte continuel des dieux
qui va maintenir et qui va diriger
toutes les choses,
même envers la rédemption
et envers la consommation des siècles.
Ok ?
C'est bon par rapport à l'ordre jusque-là ?
Et donc là, on arrive
à la considération de la doctrine de la providence.
La distinction la plus basique
et essentielle entre création et providence,
c'est que la création a à voir
avec l'acte initial des dieux
d'amener à l'existence
ce qui n'était pas.
Et dans la providence,
c'est un dieu qui va maintenir
son agence continuelle.
Ce n'est pas un dieu
qui s'éloigne de sa création
car il a déjà employé des lois
qui peuvent maintenir la machine.
Mais c'est un dieu qui est là,
bien présent,
qui va imprégner cette création.
En lui, nous vivons,
nous avons les mouvements et l'être.
Et donc, c'est un dieu
qui continue à remplir
et à diriger,
à garder en continuité cet univers.
Donc ça, c'est juste une introduction
pour l'idée de la providence.
On va définir la providence
ou la doctrine avec plus de clarté plus tard.
Et un mot par rapport
à l'importance pour nous,
la pertinence pour nous
d'étudier la doctrine de la providence.
On sait que dans certaines périodes
de l'Église,
certaines doctrines deviennent
plus importantes que d'autres
à cause des hérésies
et des défis culturels.
Voilà pourquoi les confessions
des fois sont très importantes.
importantes,
non seulement car on traite
plusieurs doctrines importantes
pour notre foi,
pour préserver notre foi
telle qu'elle est révélée
dans la Bible,
mais certaines articulations
pour expliquer
certaines vérités bibliques,
elles deviennent encore plus solides,
encore plus fortes
à cause des challenges
des hérésies de son époque.
Dans les premiers siècles
de l'Église,
c'était surtout la christologie,
c'était des personnes
qui doutaient de la double nature
du Christ
ou de la doctrine de la Trinité.
Donc dans ces périodes-là,
c'est là où on a
les plus développées
dans les premiers siècles
de l'Église,
la compréhension biblique
fidèle
et des déclarations articulées
dans les credos
et dans les confessions
qui défendent la christologie.
On peut penser
que pendant la réforme protestante,
quelle serait la doctrine
la plus importante
selon vous ?
Voilà,
la justification par la foi.
Et donc là,
la justification par la foi,
seule,
pour faire cette distinction
envers la distorsion catholique
de dire
qu'on pourrait compléter
l'œuvre du Christ
ou qu'on devrait maintenir
notre foi
par nos œuvres.
Et donc,
ce n'est pas un salut
par les œuvres,
mais la justification
par la foi seule.
Donc pendant cette période,
c'est là où on a eu
les plus grandes articulations
de la foi biblique
par rapport à la justification
par la foi seule.
et certains considèrent
que les siècles 20
et même les siècles 21
doivent surtout protéger
et préserver
la doctrine de la providence.
Ce n'est pas pour dire
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
plus importante
que ces autres doctrines,
christologie
ou justification par la foi,
car elles,
elles sont vraiment centrales
et capitales
par rapport au salut.
mais la doctrine de la providence,
elle peut apporter
beaucoup de réconfort
à l'Église
dans toutes les générations
et c'est ces détachements.
Par exemple,
il y a une implication
de la doctrine arminienne.
Donc,
il croit à la providence,
à la souveraineté de Dieu
quelque part
dans la providence,
mais ça a une capacité
de diminuer.
En fait,
quand on pense
que Dieu n'a pas
les contrôles absolus
de toutes les circonstances,
qu'il ne gouverne pas
toutes les choses,
des fois,
on essaye de défendre Dieu
de certaines difficultés
en lançant les personnes
dans une difficulté
encore plus grande.
Car si Dieu n'est pas celui
qui a les contrôles complets
de toutes les circonstances,
même lorsqu'il y a
un Covid nous surprend
ou un tsunami
survient sur une nation,
on est en train
de suggérer
que certaines choses
échappent
au contrôle de Dieu
ou qu'elles se passent
des manières
à surmonter sa puissance
car il est tout simplement
en train de permettre
les choses.
À partir du moment
où on est en train
de suggérer
que Dieu n'a pas
la toute-puissance
ni la toute-sagesse
ou la capacité
de converger
les mâles ambiants,
on est en train
de diminuer Dieu
de sa divinité.
Et des personnes
qui sont devant un Dieu
incapable
de gouverner
toutes les choses,
de contrôler
elles n'ont pas
un Dieu suffisamment
capable
de nous réconforter
dans les moments
de tragédie.
Donc ça,
c'est intéressant.
La Providence
est dans nos jours,
dans les temps présents,
possiblement,
l'une des doctrines
les plus importantes
à être abordées
car on a eu
un développement
d'une mentalité,
surtout dans l'Occident,
qui est devenue
quelque part
très réduite
au raisonnement
scientifique.
c'est-à-dire
la science,
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait ?
Elle a tout simplement
exploré
la création
des dieux
et les lois
que Dieu a établies
pour maintenir
la continuité
des choses.
Mais le problème,
c'est qu'ils ont
fermé leur compréhension
de l'univers
au naturalisme
et dans le naturalisme,
c'est comme si
les systèmes
étaient fermés.
Dieu aurait pu
peut-être
tout simplement
donner les cordes
dans l'horloge,
établir des lois,
et ils peuvent
jusqu'à reconnaître
parfois
qu'une divinité
aurait pu
ou aurait dû
peut-être être
à l'origine des choses,
mais comme on était
émerveillés
quelque part
avec la découverte
des lois qui sont là,
on a donné un saut
en plus,
complètement irraisonnable,
pour suggérer
que ce système
est fermé
et Dieu ne peut pas
intervenir.
Et donc,
on pense que
les choses
sont en train
de se passer
vulnérables
tout simplement
aux phénomènes
scientifiques
qui parfois
peuvent être
hasardeuses,
ou tout simplement
un système fermé
sans intervention
ou sans contrôle
direct de la part
des dieux.
Et donc,
pour nous,
c'est très important
de restaurer,
même envers
l'évangélisation,
c'est important
pour nous
de savoir
comment défendre
et démontrer
même des évidences
dans les présents
de ces mantiens
directs
des dieux
et même
dans l'histoire.
Et donc,
une chose
importante
d'un côté,
c'est de savoir
en fait,
voilà,
les défis
de nos jours,
c'est d'expliquer
comment Dieu
peut être
les dieux
de la Providence
si nous voyons
la dégradation
morale
de l'humanité
telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
et si nous voyons
même les guerres
qui continuent
d'être présentes.
Dans les siècles
20,
c'était très difficile
pour certains
sous cette influence
déjà
de la science
positiviste
de justifier
les dieux
de la Providence
devant les deux
grandes guerres
mondiales.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment parfois
les personnes
ont du mal
à trouver
une espèce
de réconfort
dans des temps
difficiles
car dans leur
compréhension
de la Providence,
certaines tragédies
ne peuvent pas
faire partie
des plans
des dieux
ou du contrôle
sur toutes les choses
et donc,
nous,
on doit corriger ça
pour échapper
cette réalité
et pour échapper
aussi
de la conclusion
de l'extrême
envers,
c'est une espèce
de fatalisme.
Si c'est Dieu
qui est au contrôle
de toutes les choses,
pourquoi dois-je
participer
où se trouve
ma responsabilité
dans toutes ces choses ?
Et donc,
la Providence
des dieux
ne supprime pas
les causes
ou les moyens
secondaires
comme on verra,
mais c'est important
de considérer
la pertinence
d'étudier ces sujets
à cause
de ces choses-là.
Et pour nous,
en fait,
nous,
les chrétiens,
c'est tout simplement
important
car il y a
quelques conceptions
comme la conception
des prières,
par exemple,
ou la conception
des miracles
qui présupposent
clairement
un Dieu présent,
un Dieu qui intervient.
Et donc,
si nous croyons
dans la prière,
il faut croire
nécessairement
dans un Dieu souverain
qui interagit
et qui intervient
dans ces mondes
pour répondre
à nos prières
et même parfois
pour suspendre
les lois
qu'il lui-même
a créées
qui ne peuvent
pas les limiter
et opérer
des miracles.
Et donc,
si nous croyons
tout simplement
dans cette conception
des prières
ou des miracles,
nous devons considérer
que tout cela
est lié
à la notion
de la providence.
Nous devons
toujours reconnaître,
comme on a fait
avec toutes les doctrines
jusqu'ici,
surtout,
en fait,
ces trois doctrines-là
que nous sommes
devant un mystère,
surtout quand on considère
l'interaction
entre, par exemple,
les décrets des dieux
et la responsabilité
humaine
ou la providence
souveraine des dieux
et cette providence
qui s'accomplit
à travers les moyens
secondaires
dont nous faisons partie
et dont nous sommes
responsables aussi.
Et donc là,
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que nous sommes
à nouveau devant
une doctrine
très difficile,
mystérieuse,
mais,
voilà,
c'est surtout
les manques
de foi,
c'est l'incrédulité
qui veulent éviter,
en fait,
d'embrasser
la vérité biblique.
Nous ne devons pas
avoir,
voilà,
l'espoir
de tout expliquer
ou de tout comprendre
mais d'aller
jusqu'à où
la Bible va
et embrasser
l'enseignement biblique.
OK ?
Et donc,
pour passer directement
au traitement
de la doctrine,
la première chose
qu'il faut dire,
c'est qu'il nous semble
devant une doctrine
qui est explicitement
biblique.
On devrait,
on ferait bien
de commencer
toujours par la Bible
avant de commencer
avec nos propres
circonstances
et d'essayer
de comprendre
la providence
de Dieu.
On doit aller
vers la Bible
pour voir,
en fait,
que Dieu a toujours
travaillé de manière
souveraine
en ayant le contrôle
de toutes les choses,
comme par exemple
les cas des Job,
même si les tragédies
sont là,
même si les difficultés
sont là.
Donc,
nous ne pouvons jamais
permettre
que nos crises
personnelles
nous empêchent
de voir
ce qui est clairement
enseigné
dans la parole
de Dieu.
Et car si nous faisons
les mouvements
envers,
nous serons
beaucoup plus facilement
débarrassés
de nos crises
personnelles
et beaucoup plus
réconfortés
si nous permettons
que Dieu parle
d'abord
par une lecture
fidèle
et soumise
de sa parole.
Et donc,
c'est une doctrine
clairement explicitement
biblique.
Nous allons voir,
c'est là,
comme on a fait déjà
par la lecture
de psaume 104
qui est vraiment
très claire.
Une chose
que je vous ai
encouragé à remarquer
et je vous encourage
à les refaire,
c'est de relire
en notant
comment,
à plusieurs reprises,
même ce qui est
considéré
comme la responsabilité
entre guillemets
des agents libres,
lorsqu'il dit par exemple
que même
les lions saut,
lorsqu'ils sortent
les soirs,
ils attendent
des jeux
leur soutien.
Ils vont faire
usage
de leur instinct,
de leur maîtrise
pour la chasse,
mais ils seront
quand même
toujours dépendants
que Dieu lui-même
pourvoie.
Et même à travers
la maintenance
de ses facultés,
même les systèmes
du soleil,
l'eau
qui tombe
et qui va courir
par les rivières
pour nourrir
les animaux.
Donc là,
on voit que c'est
Dieu lui-même
qui fait le soleil
s'élever,
c'est Dieu
qui pourvoie
la pluie,
etc.
Donc c'est un Dieu
qui agit
activement
au contrôle
de toutes les choses
que nous voyons.
Et donc c'est un Dieu
très participatif,
bien présent
dans sa création.
Et donc,
en termes
d'introduction,
c'est important
de remarquer
dans l'enseignement
biblique
que la providence
biblique s'oppose
à la conception
qu'on appelle
déiste.
Les déistes,
ce sont ceux
qui peuvent
jusqu'à...
Merci beaucoup,
mon frère.
Ils peuvent jusqu'à...
Non, merci.
jusqu'à...
Réconnaître,
par exemple,
voilà,
une divinité
qui a pu déclencher
l'univers,
mais il était
comme en
fabriquant
d'horloges.
OK ?
C'est comme si
Dieu avait établi
toutes les lois,
il a déclenché
la chose,
il a,
comment on dit,
tourné les cordes,
c'est ça ?
Oui,
il a montré
le mécanisme.
Et il a lâché
l'univers,
il n'intervient plus.
Donc ça,
c'est la conception
déiste.
Mais ça,
c'est les contraires.
Donc l'illustration
publique,
c'est Dieu
qui est plutôt
celui qui va
être comme
les capitaines
d'un grand navire
qui a l'univers
et c'est lui
qui va diriger
les coursus
de toutes les choses
dans les détails
et dans les générales.
Et donc,
la doctrine
de la Providence
nous enseigne
que l'univers
et tout ce qui est
dans cet univers
est comme un grand bateau
où il est piloté,
il est dirigé
à chaque jour,
à chaque heure,
à chaque minute,
à chaque seconde
par Dieu lui-même.
Il n'y a aucun instant
où Dieu ne soit pas
en train de diriger
les coursus
de l'histoire
et la maintenance
de toutes les choses
qui sont en existence.
La Providence,
selon la Bible,
elle est aussi
différente
et opposée
à la conception
du panthéisme.
Donc là,
il y a cette confusion aussi
dans un autre extrême.
Ce n'est pas un Dieu
qui soit éloigné
de sa création,
mais c'est un Dieu
qui soit tellement présent
de sa création
qu'il soit confondu
avec la création
elle-même.
Et c'est ça
qui donne
de la marge
pour, par exemple,
même ceux
qui se déclarent
irreligieux,
mais dans nos jours,
c'est très commun
avec cette pensée positive
qui a envahi même
les églises
avec une version évangélique
de la parole réma
ou des prières
déterministes.
Et donc,
c'est comme si
on était en train
de mentaliser les choses
et forcer l'univers
à faire quelque chose
pour nous
car nous sommes
un avec l'univers,
nous sommes une partie
de cette divinité
qui est partout
et nous aussi
nous sommes partis.
Donc,
l'épanthéisme,
c'est tout est Dieu,
Dieu est tout
et quelque part,
ma connexion
envers cette divinité
fait que ma mentalisation,
mes vibrations positives
vont produire
les changements
dans les circonstances.
Nous,
on ne croit pas à ça,
on croit dans les dieux
de la providence,
c'est les dieux souverains,
distants de sa création
et toutefois,
sa création subsistant Dieu,
c'est Dieu,
il est en train
d'imprégner toutes les choses,
toutes les choses subsistant Dieu
et ce n'est pas
par ma mentalisation
des changements
de circonstances
que les circonstances
qui seront changées.
Je n'ai pas
une puissance
envers Dieu
pour les forcer
à faire quoi que ce soit,
je peux intercéder
et supplier
ces dieux
qui a les contrôles
de toutes les choses
pour qu'ils changent
les circonstances
selon sa volonté.
Vous êtes avec moi,
les prières sont un moyen
à travers lesquels
Dieu aime bien agir
mais elles ne sont pas
déterministes,
elles ne déterminent pas
les cursos des choses,
elles sont toujours
dépendantes
de la volonté,
de l'accord de Dieu,
de la grâce des dieux
mais nous croyons en Dieu
qui n'est pas les dieux
du panthéisme
ni du déisme.
Donc c'est important
de faire cette distinction
entre l'enseignement biblique
de la providence
et d'autres notions
de comment Dieu
aurait pu interagir
avec les choses
qu'il a créées
pour les maintenir
en existence.
Et donc,
ensuite,
la question
qu'on peut se poser
pour être sûr
qu'il s'agit
d'une doctrine
explicitement biblique,
c'est de poser la question
mais comment nous trouvons
par exemple
dans la Bible
cette doctrine.
Donc avant de parcourir
certains textes bibliques,
on peut dire tout simplement
qu'on a énormément
de textes bibliques
comme on verra,
qui sont directs,
qui font des déclarations
directes du fait
que Dieu est au contrôle,
en train de gouverner,
diriger
ou en train de soutenir
et préserver
toutes les choses
qui existent.
mais il y a encore
l'effet des prophéties
et ça,
c'est très important
car,
voilà,
une mauvaise compréhension,
une hérésie même,
mais une mauvaise compréhension
plutôt,
surtout des courants
arminiennes,
c'est de suggérer
en fait
que tout ce
qui la Bible parle
à propos
de la providence
des dieux
ou à propos
des décrets
des dieux
est fondé
tout simplement
sur la prévision
des choses.
Par contre,
les prophéties,
elles ne sont jamais
vulnérables
à la simple
prévision des choses.
Dieu ne peut
que faire
des prophéties
qu'il assure
qu'ils vont s'accomplir
s'il n'a pas
la capacité
de gouverner
toutes les circonstances
afin de les conduire.
Donc,
c'est plutôt l'inverse.
Ce n'est pas
que la prophétie
soit basée
sur la prévision
car,
à plusieurs reprises,
la prophétie,
elle assume
et elle déclare
l'assurance
des circonstances,
les changements
même des circonstances
et parfois même
les changements
des cœurs
envers la conversion
que c'est plutôt
la préscience
qui est fondée
sur les décrets,
la préscience
qui est fondée
sur la souveraineté
des dieux
car Dieu,
il assure
qu'il va faire
les choses
car Dieu sait
qu'il va faire
les choses
basées sur sa
toute-puissance,
sur sa résolution
glorieuse et sainte
qu'il peut nous dire
ce qu'il va faire
en avance.
Il peut dire
en avance
ce qu'il va faire.
Il peut voir
ce qu'il va faire
en avance
car il assure
que c'est lui-même
qui conduit l'histoire,
que personne ne peut
résister à sa volonté
et c'est de cette manière
que la Bible nous enseigne
et donc l'effet
des prophéties
n'est pas simplement
la prévision
c'est plutôt
l'assurance.
C'est la garantie
que ce qui Dieu
a prophétisé
lui-même
va mener à terme
en conduisant
chaque événement,
chaque cause et effet
qui va conduire
à ce que Dieu
a planifié,
a déclaré,
a décréé,
ce qu'il est résolu
à faire.
C'est lui qui fait
toutes les choses
selon les conseils
de sa libre volonté.
Les faits de prophétie
donc
sont des évidences
bibliques
qui ne peuvent
que s'accomplir
car Dieu
est en train
d'interagir,
d'intervenir,
de conduire l'histoire
et aussi
l'effet des prières
comme on a déjà évoqué.
Donc,
la prière
n'aurait pas de sens
et voilà pourquoi
les déistes
ne croient pas
dans les prières
et donc
d'ailleurs
c'est une question
des fois
que j'ai déjà
entendue
aussi même
entre les chrétiens.
Je connais
une personne
très proche
de notre famille
qui a développé
ses propres idées
à propos de Dieu
et une chose
qui pour lui
ne fait pas de sens
c'est la prière
car si Dieu
est un Dieu
par exemple
souverain,
il va faire
tout ce qu'il veut faire
et s'il est omniscient,
il connaît déjà
tout ce dont on a besoin,
la question
qu'il se pose
c'est pourquoi prier
et la réalité
c'est que
nous devons prier
car Dieu
il a établi
toutes ces lois-là
donc sinon
aucune loi
n'aurait aucune
nécessité d'existence,
aucune loi
de maintenance
donc la loi
de notre système
digestif par exemple.
Si Dieu veut
qu'on soit vivant
on serait tout simplement
vide et vivant.
Vous êtes avec moi
et donc Dieu
il aime bien agir
à travers les lois secondaires
et les prières
c'est une interaction
réelle entre Dieu
et son peuple
des interactions
qui vont mener
à terme
les plans éternels
des dieux
et donc voilà pourquoi
si Dieu
n'intervient pas
la prière
n'a pas de sens
et les faits
que Dieu intervienne
ne peut pas signifier
les fatalismes
de ne pas prier
vous êtes avec moi
l'hypercalvinisme
dans un extrême
et l'idéisme
dans un autre extrême
ok
donc l'idéisme
va dire
Dieu n'intervient pas
donc il n'y a pas
de sens pour prier
et certains
les hérésies
hypercalvinistes
c'est
comme
Dieu est souverain
et va faire
ce qu'il veut
ça ne change pas
si on prie ou non
et la réalité biblique
c'est qu'elle affirme
que nous avons
la responsabilité
des prières
car Dieu
va intervenir
tel qu'il a décrété
tel qu'il veut
à travers aussi
nos prières
mais les faits
des prières
elles sont tout simplement
l'attente
que Dieu intervienne
c'est la supplication
pour que Dieu
intervienne
vous êtes avec moi
et voilà pourquoi
ça fait du sens
pour nous
des prières
donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup plus
d'autres arguments
pour nous encourager
à la prière
donc tout simplement
l'amour que Dieu a
car Dieu n'est pas
tout simplement
un Dieu
apathique
ok
il n'est pas
dominé par ses
émotions
ou par ses passions
et donc Dieu
est un père céleste
donc il a du plaisir
par la communion
avec nos prières
donc il aime bien
entendre nos prières
aussi
si je voulais rajouter
mais là je sors un peu
de l'argument
c'est tout simplement
les prières
et les réponses
aux prières
qu'on trouve dans la Bible
sont des évidences
bibliques
qui prouvent
que notre Dieu
interagit
il intervient
dans les mondes
à travers les prières
donc les faits
des miracles aussi
comme on a déjà évoqué
donc si Dieu
était on va dire
complètement interdit
d'interagir avec ces mondes
ou si Dieu
était toujours obligé
à agir
par les lois secondaires
qu'il avait établies
les miracles n'auraient pas lieu
car les miracles
parfois
c'est une manière
extraordinaire
d'agir
à travers les lois
qu'il a créées
ou de suspendre même
ou agir même
contre ces lois
qu'il a créées
et donc
un prochain aspect
qu'on va
définir aujourd'hui
c'est la définition
de la doctrine
donc de la doctrine
une définition
un peu plus formelle
un peu plus riche
si vous voulez
et donc je vous cite
la doctrine de la providence
et cet exercice continuel
de la puissance divine
par laquelle
les créateurs
il est en train de soutenir
toutes ces créatures
il est opérant
en tous ceux
qui habitent
ou qui existent
dans les mondes
et il est en train
de diriger
toutes les choses
pour l'effort
qui lui-même
a pointé
c'est de trouver
toujours
les meilleurs moyens
pour les fins
les plus élevés
mais c'est important
car compris
dans la providence
de Dieu
comme on voit
dans les cas
de Nabucco de Nazare
par exemple
c'est que même
les fonctionnements
de la faculté humaine
et même
les fonctionnements
de la faculté humaine
des impies
c'est quelque chose
que Dieu lui-même
est en train de soutenir
s'il supprime
les soutiens
du bon fonctionnement
de nos facultés
nous allons nous comporter
comme des bêtes sauvages
comme c'était le cas
de Nabucco de Nazare
vous vous rappelez
donc Dieu
il est continuellement
en train
de soutenir
et il y a
donc trois aspects
ou trois éléments
qui nous remarquons
dans cette définition
de la providence
donc il y a
d'abord
la conception
des préservations
les premiers éléments
c'est cette manière
continuelle
par laquelle
Dieu travaille
pour maintenir
la chose
qu'il a créée
et avec
la chose
qu'il a créée
toutes les propriétés
ou toutes les facultés
ou toutes les puissances
avec lesquelles
il a
conçu
ces choses
donc l'homme
quand on a étudié
l'homme
par exemple
on a plusieurs puissances
plusieurs facultés
on a
la force
on a les corps
on a les fonctions
de notre corps
on a les facultés
la personnalité
les raisonnements
et donc
Dieu non seulement
est en train de nous
maintenir en tant qu'être humain
mais il est en train
de maintenir
chacun de ses aspects
c'est Dieu
par exemple
la raison
pour laquelle
à cet instant même
je n'ai pas un AVC
par exemple
c'est lui
qui est
le responsable
pour les maintiens
de ma vie
et de toutes mes facultés
et donc là
on pourrait parler
non seulement
du soleil
et du système soleil
qu'il a créé
mais même
toutes les forces
magnétiques
qui gardent l'équilibre
entre les systèmes solaires
tels qu'ils fonctionnent
aujourd'hui
donc c'est un Dieu
dont
si on pourrait penser
à une télé
ou un ordinateur
avec la prise
de l'énergie
dont on a besoin
c'est Dieu
qui est là
en train de
maintenir
l'énergie
de tout l'univers
pour sa préservation
donc c'est Dieu
qui est en train
de préserver
toutes les choses
qu'il a faites
dans un travail
continuel
de maintenance
et donc
pour certains
ils veulent tout simplement
suggérer
que c'est juste
les faits
ou la préservation
veut dire
que Dieu
n'est pas en train
de détruire
ce qu'il a créé
mais ce n'est pas
que ça le cas
c'est Dieu
qui maintient
activement
toutes les choses
en existence
certains ont déjà
fait confusion
avec cette doctrine
même les grands
Jonathan Edwards
donc par rapport à lui
on devrait lire
tout ce qu'on trouve
donc c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de très solide
mais pour certains
c'est comme si Dieu
était en train
de créer
continuellement
toutes les choses
mais la Bible
est très claire
lorsqu'elle dit
que Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
d'une fois pour toutes
et qu'il préserve
toutes les choses
et donc il y a
donc cette notion
des lois
de préservation
et même
des multiplications
la préservation
des êtres vivants
qui vont se multiplier
par les lois
des reproductions
et donc ici
l'emphase biblique
c'est tout simplement
c'est Dieu
qui préserve
même les fonctionnements
de ces lois
c'est pas comme si
Dieu était en train
de créer
à chaque fois
toutes les choses
même si
par exemple
dans les passages
de l'Op. 104
tu envoies ton esprit
les choses sont créées
et ainsi
tu renouvelles
toutes les choses
donc là on voit
qu'il y a
la suggestion
dans notre compréhension
des nouvelles créations
mais la réalité
c'est que
l'Epsomme
est en train
de pointer
envers
les systèmes
des reproductions
naturelles
de toutes les choses
il est en train
d'attribuer à Dieu
même les lois
secondaires
qu'il est en train
de soutenir
donc toutes les choses
que Dieu a créées
a une existence
permanente
de soi-même
quelque part
nous sommes vivants
à cause de tous
les systèmes
qui sont en train
de bien fonctionner
dans nos corps
par contre
tous ces systèmes
que Dieu a créés
c'est lui-même
qui est en train
de soutenir
l'existence
ils ne sont pas
auto-existants
de soi-même
et c'est par là
qu'on est en train
de considérer
cette réalité
donc Dieu n'est pas
en train
de créer
constamment
Dieu est en train
de maintenir
les lois
qui produisent
cette reproduction
donc
quelques passages
qui peuvent corroborer
cette notion
donc les versets
28 à 30
dont je viens de mentionner
de psaume 104
mais aussi acte 17
car en lui
nous vivons
nous avons
les mouvements
et l'être
donc
non seulement
l'existence
mais nous avons aussi
la vie
les mouvements
et l'être
ok
toutes ces choses
sont en lui
Colossiens en 17
lui il est
avant toute chose
et toutes les choses
subsistent
en lui
en Christ
lui-même
et Hebreu
chapitre 1
verset 3
qui nous parle
qui Christ
est en train
de soutenir
toutes les choses
par sa parole
puissante
donc vous voyez
activement
Dieu
les Christ
ils sont en train
de soutenir
toutes les choses
de préserver
ou d'assurer
la continuité
de toutes les choses
qui restent
en existence
et en Colossiens
c'est vraiment
un abordage global
de tout l'univers
de chaque partie
et de son ensemble
donc j'ai déjà évoqué
Nabucodonosar
comme exemple aussi
c'est un autre passage
Daniel 4
donc il y a
donc
cette notion
première
des préservations
et il y a aussi
cette notion
des gouvernements
et ça c'est aussi
très important
dans la considération
de la doctrine
de la providence
donc Dieu
non seulement
est en train
de soutenir
et préserver
et par là
on aurait pu penser
à encore
une certaine
distance
des dieux
par rapport
à ce que les personnes
font
mais même
les choses
que les personnes
sont en train
de faire
sont sous
les gouvernements
des dieux
donc c'est là
où c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans la parole
des dieux
la distinction
je vais m'anticiper
déjà à quelques
difficultés
on va avoir un moment
pour traiter
quelles sont les difficultés
mais pour m'anticiper
un peu
il y a la distinction
entre l'usage
de termes
préordonnés
de la part
des dieux
ok
et les termes
prédestinés
la prédestination
quand elle est évoquée
dans la bible
elle parle exclusivement
des chrétiens
et du fait
que Dieu doit
intervenir
de manière
miraculeuse
pour nous délivrer
de l'esclavage
de notre corruption
de notre rébellion
dont nous sommes responsables
donc Dieu
n'a pas besoin
d'intervenir
dans nos vies
pour que
de nous-mêmes
avec l'usage
de notre liberté
et de notre responsabilité
on soit rebelles
contre Dieu
et on se dirige
vers l'enfer
et donc
dans la préordination
Dieu
il n'est pas
en train
d'agir
directement
dans la conduction
des êtres humains
vers les mâles
ça c'est impossible
selon les passages bibliques
mais il va même
faire un usage
et une gouvernance
de nos mauvaises actions
afin de faire
que ces choses
convergent au bien
donc c'est les types
de gouvernance
qu'on peut dire
indirect
même si
même si le terme
indirect est faible
par rapport au fait
que Dieu est celui
qui est en train
de soutenir
même les fonctionnements
pour que les agents libres
aillent dans la direction
du mal
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
Dieu va faire
un contrôle
des agences
et des mauvaises agences
afin de les faire
converger au bien
donc par exemple
Joseph
vous avez planifié
les mâles
contre moi
mais Dieu
l'a planifié
pour les biens
ok
ou
lorsque Pierre
va prêcher
en acte 2
et qu'il va dire
Christ
il a été livré
selon les conseils
arrêtés des dieux
mais malheur
à celui
par qui
les fils de l'homme
a été livré
vous comprenez
la responsabilité
des agents
méchants
et libres
l'agence
directe
du mal
et de l'homme
et Dieu
gouverne
nos agences
mauvaises
pour produire
les biens
bon je m'anticipe
mais après
on va revenir
sur ça
mais c'est juste
pour dire
que la gouvernance
des dieux
dans la providence
c'est cette activité
continue
des dieux
par laquelle
il est en train
de garder
son règne
ou sa règle
sur toutes les choses
pour les conduire
à une fin
définie
et objective
bien sûr
une fin glorieuse
et il est fait
des manières
à sécuriser
l'accomplissement
de son but
divin
ok
donc
verset très objectif
à cet égard
l'épsomme 97
verset 1
les seigneurs
règnent
et que la terre
se réjouisse
ou l'épsomme
103-19
son royaume
gouverne
sur toutes les choses
où
Isaïe 40
verset 15
les nations
sont comme
des gouttes
dans les seaux
des dieux
elles sont comptées
comme de la poussière
dans sa balance
et donc
Daniel
qui va évoquer
les faits
que Dieu
dirige
et gouverne
les cœurs
des rois
même
comme il veut
c'est Dieu
qui adoucit
les cœurs
de ses autorités
pour avoir
un égard favorable
envers Daniel
par exemple
dans son expérience
et donc
personne ne peut
résister
à sa volonté
et donc
les buts
des dieux
vont
se tenir fermes
et ils sont
toujours en train
de se développer
à chaque instant
ça devrait être
d'un réconfort
énorme
car même
des choses
qui sont apparemment
des tragédies
ou des choses
opposées
à la progression
du roiime
des dieux
comme on a vu
dans la prière
un acte 8
la dispersion
la persécution
qui augmente
et le monde entier
qui va passer
à être évangélisé
et donc
nous les chrétiens
on devrait être
les premiers
à prendre
à embrasser
tout ce que
Dieu réserve
pour nous
pour les prochains
instants de nos vies
pour la prochaine
semaine
pour les prochains jours
car Dieu
sera toujours
en train de réserver
pour nous
ce qui contribuera
à la promotion
de sa gloire
et sa sainteté
du bien
même si ça vient
déguiser
des troubles
dans notre compréhension
donc tout ce qui est
en train de se passer
à chaque instant
est en train
de contribuer
à la promotion
du but
spécifique
qui Dieu a désigné
à travers ces choses
et donc ça parle
de cet élément
des gouvernances
et le troisième élément
on a parlé
des préservations
des gouvernances
et on parle aussi
des concurrences
donc la concurrence
c'est de nous rappeler
que Dieu
agit
parfois
directement
dans la création
dans la providence
dans l'histoire
mais Dieu
il agit aussi
lui-même
il est en train
d'agir
à travers
les lois
ou les moyens
qu'on appelle
les moyens secondaires
ok
donc le troisième aspect
de la providence
c'est la concurrence
c'est la coopération
des dieux
et de sa puissance
divine
avec toutes
les puissances
subordinées
toutes les lois
pré-établies
établies
secondaires
qui opèrent
dans l'univers
qu'elle a créé
ok
et donc nous pouvons
penser aux lois
de la physique
aux lois
qui régissent
l'univers
la gravité
etc
nous pouvons penser
aussi à tous les systèmes
qui gardent
notre préservation
et toutes les agences
des êtres
notre responsabilité
nos raisonnements
etc
Dieu il est
constamment
en train d'agir
par sa gouvernance
par sa préservation
en utilisant
la concurrence
de ces choses
et donc l'idée
c'est la relation
réelle
entre
la souveraineté
des dieux
qui contrôle
toutes les choses
et la réalité
l'existence réelle
de la liberté
humaine
et
de la responsabilité
humaine
dans tout ce qu'on fait
donc c'est là
où nous devons
apprendre
à reconnaître
la limitation
de notre capacité
d'harmoniser
ces deux choses
mais nous devons
démontrer
la vraie foi
Dieu ne nous appelle
pas à être
les philosophes
qui veulent tout
comprendre
et ne veulent pas
croire à ce qu'ils
ne comprennent pas
ok
donc par exemple
je m'avance aussi
sur un autre point
une autre difficulté
mais par exemple
tous ces chrétiens
qui sont
fiers
en fait
des dernières
découvertes
de la science
et qui aiment bien
lorsque Discovery Channel
essayent d'expliquer
par la science
un miracle
biblique
à partir du moment
où on explique
par la science
c'est plus un miracle
et c'est plutôt
une démonstration
d'incrédulité
à partir du moment
où la Bible nous dit
de manière très claire
donc par exemple
je ne sais pas
quand est-ce que
j'ai vu quelque chose
qui disait
la science aujourd'hui
peut prouver
qu'il y a eu
une éclipse
les moments où Jésus
était à la croix
dans les ténèbres
à midi
nous on ne peut
ni dépendre de ça
ni être prédisposé
plus à croire à ça
que dans les récits bibliques
qui nous montrent clairement
qu'il y a un plan midi
hors des rions
ténèbres sur terre
et donc là
pour nous
c'est très important
de préserver
il y a plein de miracles
dans la Bible
c'est impossible
d'essayer de trouver
des explications scientifiques
c'est pas pour dire
que Dieu ne peut pas
faire une gouvernance
de ses propres lois
pour des manières
extraordinaires
accélérer
ou changer les circonstances
mais c'est un Dieu
dont les miracles
sont par définition
quelque chose
qu'il va surmonter
et suspendre
ses propres lois
et donc là
Dieu
il agit
par les moyens
des lois secondaires
mais il a toute la liberté
d'agir
donc la concurrence
c'est pour mettre l'emphase
sur le fait
que des bases
hormis les miracles
nous sommes devant un Dieu
qui opère
à travers ces lois
mais nous n'avons pas
la capacité
d'harmoniser
la responsabilité humaine
avec la souveraineté
de Dieu
toujours
et Dieu
il est en train
de les faire
à chaque instant
la responsabilité humaine
elle est réelle
nous serons redévas
devant Dieu
si nous ne prions pas
comme on devrait
et Dieu va agir aussi
à travers
soit la négligence
de nos prières
soit la persévérance
car il est toujours
en train d'agir
selon sa souveraineté
donc
Dieu est toujours
en train d'agir
au-dedans
et à travers
les causes
que lui-même
il a fait
donc c'est lui
qui les soutient
et c'est lui
qui agit
à travers elles
la doctrine biblique
de la providence
nous enseigne
à propos
de l'existence
des secondes causes
des causes secondaires
et en même temps
elle nous enseigne
donc voilà
l'homme est libre
mais même
la liberté de l'homme
ne peut pas agir
de manière indépendante
ou de manière
automatique
séparée
de l'action
des dieux
donc Dieu
travaille
à travers elle
donc ce qu'on doit
affirmer
c'est qu'il y a
des puissances
et lois dans la nature
mais elles ne sont pas
séparées complètement
des dieux
Dieu est à part
de la créature
mais la créature
subsiste en Dieu
et toutes ses lois aussi
donc Dieu
il est dans une relation
directe à elle
et il utilise
ses ordres
et ses libertés
pour accomplir
sa volonté
et il faut savoir
que nous sommes
devant un mystère
donc l'Epsom 104
à nouveau
pour revenir sur
ce qu'il y a
des versets
donc tu amènes
les ténèbres
et il est nuit
alors tous les animaux
des forêts
sont en mouvement
les lionceaux
rougissent après la proie
et demandent
des dieux
leur nourriture
tu envoies ton esprit
son créé
tu renouvelles
la face de la terre
donc là
ce sont à nouveau
des références
à des lois
de la nature
qu'on observe
donc par instant
les lionceaux
sortent après sa proie
mais c'est des dieux
qu'ils reçoivent
la nourriture
et la même chose
par rapport à la manière
dont on voit
la reproduction des animaux
mais c'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train
de renouveler
la face de la terre
c'est à Dieu
attribuer
l'agence
même à travers
l'éco-secondaire
Amor 3,6
est-ce que la trompette
va sonner
dans la cité
et le peuple
ne sera pas
terrorisé
est-ce qu'il y a
un mal
qui arrive à la cité
sans que les seigneurs
lui-même
l'aient fait
donc ça c'est
très intéressant
donc même
les mal
qui arrivent
donc les mal
ici c'est clair
c'est pas un mal moral
on voit qu'à plusieurs reprises
c'est le jugement
des dieux
sur notre race
rébelle
et ça c'est un acte
juste et sans
mais dans notre perspective
c'est un mal
qui arrive
et même lorsqu'un mal
est produit
comme par exemple
par Judas
Dieu est en train
de gouverner
et soutenir
les fonctionnements
de la pensée
de Judas
et permettre
qu'il va dans sa direction
mais c'est Judas
dans sa responsabilité
et sa liberté
qui est en train
de faire les mal
donc c'est pas Dieu
Dieu ne peut pas
causer les mal
il ne peut pas être
tenté par les mal
donc c'est très important
qu'on revienne
sur ces passages
qui nous protègent
d'arriver à des mauvaises conclusions
tout en reconnaissant
les difficultés
et la réalité
des affirmations bibliques
donc
Matthieu 145
car Dieu fait
que son soleil
s'élève
sur les justes
et sur les injustes
et il envoie
sa pluie
à des justes
et à des injustes
donc là
à nouveau
on peut penser
que c'est le soleil
qui chauffe la terre
et qui produit la pluie
on sait reconnaître
ces lois
mais on sait aussi
que c'est Dieu lui-même
qui est en train de les faire
et donc
on va s'arrêter ici
aujourd'hui
mais
on a considéré
les trois aspects
de la providence
nous allons ensuite
considérer les dégrés
la distinction
entre providence générale
et providence spéciale
on va toucher plus
à cette difficulté
par rapport
à la manière dont Dieu
est celui
qui soutient
et gouverne
les fonctionnalités
de toutes les choses
et comment
comprendre
par exemple
les agences
libres
pécheresses
des personnes
qui Dieu lui-même
est en train de préserver
l'existence
donc il y a quelques difficultés
que nous devons donner
un peu plus de temps
et traiter
un peu mieux
et nous allons surtout
considérer
quelques réconforts
qui nous trouvons
dans la doctrine
de la providence
dont
l'une des principales
c'est de savoir
en fait
que la providence
à la fin des comptes
elle tourne
particulièrement
autour
de l'église
quelque part
si Dieu n'était pas
en train de former
son église
en peuple pour soi
les mondes
n'auraient plus
de continuité
et quelque part
tout l'univers
tourne autour
son fonctionnement
son maintien
et même
toutes les détresses
qui nous entourent
parfois
sont en train
de produire
l'évangélisation
du peuple des dieux
la sanctification
notre approche
des dieux
et nous destiner
à la gloire céleste
donc c'est comme si
tous les restes
étaient des quadruvents
des figurants
par rapport
au but des dieux
envers son église
ok
donc on va revenir
sur ces points
et on va s'arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
et si vous voulez
vous repérer
par rapport
à la
confession des phares
on a couvert
jusqu'au
troisième paragraphe
par la considération
des sévérités
qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui
donc
je pense qu'on peut lire
juste les paragraphes
2 et 3
car on n'a pas encore lu
et on va prier
ensuite
donc paragraphe 2
du chapitre 5
par rapport
à la préscience
au décret
des dieux
la cause primaire
toute chose
arrive
immuablement
et infailliblement
de sorte que
rien n'arrive
par hasard
ou en dehors
de sa providence
par la même providence
cependant
dieu leur ordonne
de se produire
selon la nature
de ces causes
secondes
que ce soit
nécessairement
librement
ou de façon
contingente
apparemment
de façon contingente
dans sa providence
dieu
normalement
se sert des moyens
il est cependant
libre d'agir
sans ses moyens
par-dessus ses moyens
ou contre eux
si tel est son plaisir
donc la conception
des miracles
et donc
on va s'arrêter ici
les prochains
paragraphes
vont parler plus
des difficultés
qu'on doit aborder
et nous allons
enrichir notre compréhension
par là aussi
ok
vous pouvez vous anticiper
en lisant ces choses
donc si quelqu'un
peut prier pour nous
pour conclure